[Applaudissements]
voici le tableau de ma vie je m'appelle
enea j'ai 17 ans et tout comme moi vous
êtes une oeuvre d'art nous sommes tous
construits dans tableau lui même
constitué des individus et des moments
marquants de notre vie
ce tableau porte aussi toutes les
caractéristiques qui nous décrivent tels
que nous sommes façonnés
et cette oeuvre si c'est moi enfin de
façon assez abstraite comme est
symbolique
aujourd'hui si je prends la parole c'est
pour parler de ce trail en particulier
c'est le trait de mon origine ethnique
et à la différence des autres traits et
des autres coups de peinture de ce
tableau celui ci est visible
physiquement et c'est un des traits qui
a forgé la différence
ce soir je parlais de l'origine ethnique
enfin de ce qui en a malheureusement
d'écouler le racisme
je vais vous présenter ma vision du
racisme quand j'étais en primaire il me
semble que j'étais pas la seule
asiatiques nous étions trois quatre et
je me souviens que nos camarades ce
musée à brider les yeux devant nous et
clamer haut et fort chin hsiung en
passant par les chinois
je pense que quand on est enfant on ne
connaît pas la signification adhèrent à
nos propos et on a tendance à reproduire
tout ce que l'on entend et tout ce que
l'on voit donc on n'a pas assez de recul
pour se positionner sur ce qu'on dit et
sur ce qu'on fait donc je ne peux pas
affirmer que mes camarades de l'époque
était bel et bien raciste par contre si
des adultes continuent aujourd'hui à le
faire en ayant pleinement conscience de
sens derrière c'est du racisme parce que
c'est se moquer des caractéristiques
physiques et linguistiques d'un individu
vous avez donc compris la nuance dans la
notion du racisme jacques eu cette idée
que les individus sont conscients de ce
qu'ils font et ce qu'ils disent
maintenant je vais revenir sur ce trait
là je suis heureuse viennent en réalité
ma mère et taïwanaises mon père est
français et la particularité du
métissage c'est qu'on a l'impression de
n'être ni jamais assez la renie jamais
assez l'autre
ce que je trouve intéressant c'est que
la france et taiwan constituent deux
pays alors non opposé mais en tout cas
largement différent sur tous les plans
possibles alors l'un pense que je mange
du chien l'autre pense que je mangeais
d'escargots je pense qu'en termes de
culture culinaire je découvre tout le
monde
et dans métis j'ai reçu des réflexions
en france sur mon aspect asiatique
groupe canz a adopté mon chien l'une des
premières choses que l'on m'a dit avant
même de me demander son prénom c'est
faire attention à ne pas le manger
alors pour les sceptiques montchamp est
encore vivant est en très bonne santé
la phrase qui m'a marqué aussi c'est
rentrer chez toi on veut pas de toi ici
alors des phrases comme celle ci c'est
ce qu'on appelle des mini agression même
si ce n'est pas physique ce sont des
agressions verbales et c'est une forme
d' attaque
j'avais 12 ans et c'est un gars un peu
plus grand que moi qui me l'avait dit au
collège alors sur le coup j'ai eu le
très mauvais réflexe de rigoler parce
que je l'avais pas pris au sérieux mais
en y repensant le soir même je me suis
sincèrement demander pourquoi il m'avait
dit ça parce que ben chez moi ç'a
toujours été ici en france et
honnêtement cette phrase n'a pas
profondément affecté papauté m'a
interrogé sur les relations
qu'entretiennent les jeunes sur les
distinctions qui paraissent les diviser
et il ya d'autres événements récents qui
m'ont invité à penser toute cette
étiquette qu'on essayait de se coller
vous le savez sûrement le racisme anti
asiatique a pris énormément d'ampleur
avec la crise du coronavirus parce qu'on
en a certains qui assimile locaux vis de
la chine et la chine à la 10 ans assez
technique poursuivre
ça commence par des insultes et de
reproches sur internet et ça finit en
vraie violence physique dans la rue
l'année dernière en octobre 2020 il ya
eu un appel à la violence sur twitter en
france et de nombreux asiatiques ont été
la cible et aux victimes d'agressions
physiques voilà une vidéo en particulier
qui m'a interpellé c'était celle d'un
jeune homme asiatique qui invitait
toutes les personnes asiatiques à faire
attention il avait le visage enflé des
bleus aux yeux et du sang sur le visage
l'homme en question a fini aux urgences
vous vous rendez compte à quel point
c'est grave que certaines personnes
craignent encore de sortir de chez eux
de peur de se faire agresser par leur
origine ethnique encore aujourd'hui en
et tout ça ce ne sont que les
témoignages que nous voyons sur les
réseaux sociaux je pense que la réalité
bien plus effrayante
alors évidemment je pense que la
situation a évolué je vous espérez que
le racisme aujourd'hui est moins
prononcé qu'au siècle dernier
mais je vais prendre l'exemple de ma
maman d'ailleurs qui dressa donc ou
euh
parce qu'il m'est familier parce que
c'est sa situation réelle qui ment
c'était à prendre la parole ce soir
emma réveil matin raconté qu'elle
arrivait en france à une période où il
n'y avait pas beaucoup d'asiatiques et
ça suscite et des regards de curiosité
mais surtout de mépris
elle m'a expliqué que c'était dur de
trouver un travail avec le dédain des
employés de pôle emploi et leur
appréhension à l'égard de ses capacités
intellectuelles
en réalité des témoignages comme celui
ci il y en a plein mais vu qu'il vient
d'une personne qui vit mes proches c'est
beaucoup plus fort et beaucoup plus
percutant
j'ai pris l'exemple du racisme anti
asiatique pour illustrer cette idée que
le racisme est encore très ancrée
aujourd'hui et voir tous ces témoignages
entendre toutes ces vidéos et lire
toutes ces discours très triste et
pognon sur la situation de chaque
personne racisées bas honnêtement ça me
surprend vraiment mais ça m'attriste
beaucoup parce qu'il ya ce sentiment
d'impuissance on se sent désarmé face
cette situation dans laquelle on pense
qu'on peut rien faire
et j'ai réfléchi et j'en suis arrivé à
la conclusion que la disparition du
racisme était en quelque sorte
inéluctable et pour accélérer le
processus il faut que nous les jeunes
comprenant que nous avons un réel
pouvoir pour changer les choses tantôt
rapport aux autres
nous sommes les activistes d'aujourd'hui
et les actifs de demain nous avons un
réel pouvoir pour changer les choses
n'hésitez pas à vous engager pour les
causes que vous estimez importante parce
que ça a son importance vous avez votre
importance la moins de contributions
dans une action peut avoir un réel
impact à plus grande échelle au même
dans le futur donc n'hésitez pas à vous
engager
vous pensez à un processus alors non
pour totalement éradiquer le racisme ce
n'est pas moi qui détiens le miracle
mais j'ai plutôt pensé un mini guide
pour inciter tout le monde à prendre
part dans la lutte contre le racisme
j'avais ce processus les 3e et je
propose qu'on les fasse et que leur
ressemble
le premier a eu c'est éduquer c'est bien
connu l'éducation forget la nation
alors j'ai vu une étude américaine menée
sur les personnes noires ou à détroit
qui disait que le racisme qu'il
subissait
augmenter leur anxiété et augmenter le
risque de tomber malade donc leur santé
mentale est vraiment bien pire que dans
d'autres zones aux états unis
ce type d'information qui évidemment
suscite notre intérêt et on doit se
sentir concerné par cette situation
c'est des informations qu'on retrouve
facilement sur les réseaux sociaux est
donc en réalité on peut tous accéder à
cette étape de l'engagement c'est à dire
s'éduquer
la preuve le racisme est une
problématique intergénérationnel qui
doit société l'intérêt de tous donc on
doit tous s'engagent et ont séduit quand
le deuxième de s'exprimer c'est en
quelque sorte le support de l'éducation
c'est parler autour de vous un peu ce
que je fais en ce moment
il ne faut pas hésiter à reprendre
quelqu'un qui est prêt à vous écouter
par exemple ceux qui tiennent des propos
offensants penser que cela puisse nous
blesser exemple aurait expliqué que dire
tu es belle pour une femme asiatique en
compliments
donc il faut qu'on utilise notre voix ou
n'importe quel autre moyen d'expression
pour soigner les moeurs parce que c'est
le meilleur moyen de se faire entendre
et le 3e le plus important je dirais
c'est entreprendre c'est la réaction
alors y'a entreprendre et entreprend
moyens à entreprendre dans le sens de
défendre que ce soit et micro agression
ou alors de réel acte de violence
physique il ne faut pas hésiter à se
défendre physiquement et porter plainte
car je le rappelle le racisme est puni
par la loi
donc alors je comprends que la démarche
ne soit pas facile parce que même moi je
n'ai jamais été dans cette situation
donc j'aurais du mal à imaginer ma
réaction mais il ya plusieurs éléments
clés que nous pourrions avoir en tête
déjà si nous sommes tellement de racisme
que nous pouvons appeler la police ou
les deux pas de ses côtés sur 20 tirs
alors le mieux l'idéal serait de
demander de l'aide autour de nous pour
intervenir au moins à 2 dans la
situation parce que intervenir seul ça
risquerait d'en venir à ma situation et
le but n'est pas de vous mettre en
danger
et quand je dis intervenir c'est d'abord
s'assurer que la victime même si j'aime
pas trop le terme aille bien et ensuite
s'adresser de façon diplomatique à
l'agresseur
ensuite il ya également entreprendre
dans le sens de prévenir pour contrer ce
type d'agression il faut que des cours
de self-défense gratuit soit déployée
dans tous les france par exemple
également des formations de
communication non-violente doivent être
déployés dès le collège c'est à dire
apprendre à intervenir dans un conflit
savoir quoi dire quoi faire quelles sont
les choses à éviter
il faudrait également
consacré des journées entières dédiées à
la culture de la primaire pour faire
découvrir de tenues traditionnelles des
musiques traditionnelles également la
culture culinaire parce que je vous
assure qu'à taïwan on en mange pas que
du chien bon je sais des criquets cru
voilà donc si les parents parmi vous qui
va prendre l'initiative par exemple
d'intervenir dans les écoles pour
partager leur culture ça serait
incroyable pour les enfants parce que ça
va leur permettrait de se cultiver et de
voir au delà des stéréotypes avec
lesquels ils grandissent et également ce
choc de cultures permettrait une
meilleure représentation des diversités
l'école puisque je voudrais que quand
j'étais petit je pensais que la
normalité c'était la couleur blanche du
coup quand il fallait dessiner ses
parents l'école j'avais fait des cheveux
blonds et les yeux bleus à ma mère je
suis désolé je sais ce que vous dites
quelle fille en ligne
on a encore eu des sens d'ailleurs
j'aimerais qu'à l'avenir chaque enfant
puisse comprendre qu'il ne faut pas
reproduire des mimiques raciste qui vise
à se moquer leurs camarades et surtout
distingué la moquerie de l'humour
qu'il comprenne qu'il ya des choses qui
ne doivent ni être dit niet refaite
j'aimerais que chaque jeune comprennent
que nous ne devons pas avoir peur de
défendre nos amis racisées que c'est
ensemble que le changement se fait enfin
que j'aimerais que chaque parent puisse
éduquer son enfant dans le respect des
autres parce qu'en réalité ce sont eux
qui forgent les prochaines générations
et je voudrais enfin rappelé aux
personnes racisées que ce n'est pas de
leur faute et qu'elles ne doivent pas
remettre en question leur identité à
cause de ce qu'elles subissent
je m'appelle enea les 17 ans et voici le
début de ma vie alors je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué mais il ya un truc
qui s'est rajoutée par rapport à la
première heure que je vous ai compris au
début c'est ce trait rouge et il
représente mon expérience du teide ma
rencontre avec vous
et comme je voulais zim chaque humain
est une toile blanche à la naissance
puis tenté de vie à la mort
certains traits reste visible à vis
d'autres sont recouverts au fil du temps
sont toujours là dans le fond mais on ne
les voit plus malheureusement
et chaque tableau unique de la même
façon que chaque être est unique notre
origine ethnique est une donnée
différence mais n'est pas la seule rep a
caractérisé la totalité notre identité
c'est simplement un petit trait par
mille en océan d'humanité de couleurs un
petit raid on doit être fier c'est sûr
mais qui ne devrait pas nous décrire
entièrement
alors cette réflexion ne concerne pas
seulement l'origine ethnique mais
également toutes les caractéristiques
qui semble nous éloigner de la
soi-disante normes je ne suis pas
seulement se traîne nous ne sommes pas
seulement nos différences
finalement les humains sont
complémentaires et se construisent
ensemble avant un enterrement en
peignant sur la toile de chacun bien
qu'elle n'ait pas de sens notre
existence est nécessaire
n'oubliez jamais que l' aventure humaine
peut être la plus belle des expériences
si on arrive à comprendre la singularité
de notre oeuvre merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]